the FBI intends to meet its one-week
deadline even with this expanded scope
of the inquiry but it's working under a
lot of pressure
Jeff McGee's is reporting out this story
for us so Jeff tell us what you've been
hearing yeah well as he said this is
gonna be another long week and of course
this is no ordinary inquiry that's what
they're calling it it's essentially a
background check a former top FBI
official who's been in contact with
those involved in the inquiry at the
bureau described a war room atmosphere
around this case agents are talking to
the people at the core of the
allegations them working their way out
to try to corroborate the information
one former top FBI official who is
familiar with these enquiries says that
that includes trying to locate records
from a grocery store where Marc judge
worked lawyer for judge who Christine
Blasi Ford alleges was in the room when
the attack took place as Judge spoke
with the FBI but his interview has not
been completed judge previously said
that he did not recall the events
described by Ford in her testimony a
lawyer for Patrick Smith who for also
alleges was at the party said in a
statement that Smith has fully
cooperated with the FBI but he indicated
he has no knowledge of the small party
or gathering described now because this
is an inquiry and not an investigation
or criminal probe the FBI cannot compel
anyone to talk to them and these
witnesses have no obligation to
cooperate and at its conclusion the FBI
will present an interview summaries of
the interviews and corroborating
materials in the White House but of
course they're not going to come up with
any conclusions in this case the White
House is the client and they are
delivering this background check product
to the client so so given that it's not
going to exonerate anybody or condemn
anybody particular it's just gathering
of evidence and information how does the
FBI feel about having to do this listen
this is another one of those case where
there is dread within the FBI why
because once again their thrust into the
center of a political firestorm and
exactly it's like the Russia
investigation in a way for them so you
know they're caught in the middle of
this storm and no matter which way this
goes they're not going to come out
smelling like a rose and I did talk to a
former assistant director of
the FBI Chris Walker who says you know
they're gonna have their best agents on
this case and they're going to treat it
like any other background check for the
FBI and they're gonna do this just like
it were any other case that's why I
think what you just said about reporting
that it's really an inquiry and not an
investigation I think setting people's
acton Department that no matter how it
turns out a whole lot of people on one
side are not going to be happy yeah that
what this is heading yeah right a
federal bureau of handling hot potatoes
thank you Jeff yeah